i'm curious is there anything with
being a v tuber over the past year that
you've learned is like
annoyingly difficult that other people
would just never consider oh let me
think this is a tough one um
one sec no worries nothing because there
are a lot of things that are good
because i feel like i don't appreciate
how difficult it can be sometimes yeah i
just look at them and i just think oh
wow you guys don't have to worry about
how you look you can just
channel the model that's great i'm so
jealous i mean there's a lot of stuff
you know behind the scenes that we have
to do is the thing oh yeah
you know they see us for like um maybe
like two three hours if you stream for a
short amount of time if you do like an
endurance stream eight hours sure but
here's the thing though when we we press
like go live and like after we're done
stop the stream immediately what i do is
i go sit on the couch and i start making
thumbnails i make a bunch of thumbnails
for the week then i have to make the
schedule which you know last night took
about an hour and a half so you make the
thumbnails yourself yes oh my god i
think i think most youtubers do right
that's the one thing i'm so impressed
with youtubers is that they always have
like unique thumbnails for everything
and i'm like i didn't realize how
grateful i am that twitch you don't have
to do that how did you learn how to do
that because like like
not not to be like a dumb question but
thumbnails are like a very fine arts
that you a lot of youtubers learn as
they go along i mean i didn't know how
to make no i didn't know how to make
good thumbnails until like a year or two
after i'd start doing i mean there's
people on the platform that have been on
for like 10 years that still don't know
how to make it yeah yeah yeah exactly i
mean it's something that you just kind
of learn along the way because for me i
had no idea my thumbnail game was real
week before but i had to get good at it
you know and i started kind of seeing
what others did as well and not
completely taking everything that
everyone did but little things here and
there that i'd i noticed and be like i
should i should do like a stroke layer
on this text like this and it'll look a
lot better and a drop shadow here and
that kind of stuff and it's all just
like fine fine little things you'd never
really think super hard about but they
do make a difference yeah exactly how
long do you guys spend on your
thumbnails
um i try to do as little as possible
yeah i try and outsource it as much
see this guy's working smart i think i
spend maybe like max 30 minutes
i'm quite short when it comes to
something i feel like if you have the
capacity to pay someone else to do
something you should pay someone else to
do something
no but like there's it's work it's
business i i want more time to do my
stuff not exactly but for some people
they value the truth sound privilege i
know [ __ ] yeah shut up you're pretty
chad laughing at me
yeah i mean the thing is uh for example
for v tubers there are so many of them
that want to be in control of their own
thumbnails that like it becomes a
creativity thing i feel like thumbnails
are important because with you you've
got an artist doing a lot of your
thumbnails and aside from that it's like
taking the perfect shot on scene or
something whereas my thumbnails can take
up to like some some thumbnails i can
outsource some icon because even i don't
know how to market some of my videos
right i don't know for me like when you
upload twice a week or
recently once a month you need to make
that [ __ ] thumbnail
no sorry sorry twice a month twice a
month uh
once every two weeks you need to make
those thumbnails count like with trash
taste it's just like easy
if one thumbnail doesn't hit you got
next week with me i'm just like if this
thumbnail doesn't hit i'm gonna wait a
[ __ ] month man like that [ __ ] hurts
have you thought about perhaps uploading
more often
well that means
that means making content better
faster to make yeah yeah
you know there's less pressure on making
that perfect thumbnail all right
i am making as much content as i
possibly can joy please okay
i mean i think another thing that people
also don't realize is um one big factor
is just
simply um
the energy it takes to be you all the
time yeah yeah um when i'm putting up a
schedule for a new stream i gotta put in
a description that i think kind of you
know either matches or is this too much
am i saying too many things in the
description you overthink a lot in this
channel am i going to put out a tweet
that like says a lot of things or like
one sentence a couple words you have to
always think about this kind of stuff
you know and um scheduling meetings as
well that's another big